je
pour l'instant
ce mélange
mesdames et messieurs voici leur venue
de la conférence de presse
traditionnelle à l'issue d'un conseil
européen
c'est dire que les travaux sont terminés
que la concurrence maintenant se
dispersent et qu'il nous faut gérer les
décisions prises je le ferai de façon
très schématique une part j'imagine que
vous avez été tenu informé de
l'essentiel et d'autre part ce sont les
questions que vous me poserez qui
permettront d'approfondir tel ou tel
aspect de nos débats et de nos
résolutions
je vais donc énuméré les sujets abordés
à la conférence de fontainebleau
d'abord nous avons examiné la situation
internationale
cela a occupé l'essentiel de la matinée
d'hier autour d'un rapport celui de
madame thatcher qui présidait la
conférence de londres réunissait les
pays industrialisés laquelle conférence
avait traité de nombreux sujets d'ordre
économique traité de certains problèmes
politiques en particulier dans la
relation avec le tiers-monde et sur la
base de cette relation faite par madame
thatcher quelques précisions ont été
apportées par les autres participants
c'était 4 puis ce président la
commission donc 5 de londres afin de
connaître l'opinion des autres membres
de la communauté qui n'était pas présent
à londres cela de l'est l'objet à
certains nombres de des chances de vue
qui ont été utiles j'ai également
relater ce qui me paraît devoir être
l'essentiel de mon propre voyage en
union soviétique
après quoi nous avons abordé les
contentieux ou ce qu'il en restait
jusqu'à bruxelles
la plupart avaient été résolus mais
plusieurs avaient été tenus en l'état
pas la non résolution du problème
communément appelée la contribution
britannique s'est ajoutée en cours de
route une discussion sur une proposition
allemande tendance à faire varier la tva
pour la production agricole de ce pays
je centrerait si vous venez dans le
détail dans un instant sur la
contribution britannique
la discussion a abouti à un accord
l'essentiel de cet accord donné tout de
suite en 1984 un forfait d'un milliard
dès qu en 1985 ou à partir de 1985
pourcentage sur le déficit britannique
sans que soit décompté les prélèvements
agricoles et les droits de douane je ne
sais si vous vous souvenez que ce débat
avait déjà eu lieu à bruxelles autour
d'une somme totale estimée par la
royaume uni à 2 milliards des culs et
comprenant comme c'était le cas depuis
1980 c'était la corde et 1980 les droits
de douane et les prélèvements à l'école
d'où un débat de fond s'était engagée
déjà depuis quelques temps
un certain nombre de pays dont la france
estimant qu'il s'agissait là de
ressources communautaires qui n'avait
pas à être décompté en plus de la tva
elle ressources nationales ce qui ramené
le total à quelque chose autour d'un
milliard 600 millions
bien entendu un pourcentage appliqué à
une somme réduite ne donne pas le même
résultat que à pourcentage appliqué à la
somme totale donc sans prélèvement ni
droits de douane ce pourcentage étant de
66%
vous savez que les demandes initiales
étaient produits conviennent antique
discussions nettement plus élevés et que
finalement on en est arrivé à une donnée
qui nous laisse très en deçà des accords
initiaux de 1980 et qui aboutisse parce
que chacun ya mis du sien à une somme
jugée raisonnable par l'unanimité de la
conférence une telle décision comporte
diverses conséquences en particulier
elle débloque le problème des ressources
propres l'augmentation des ressources
propres à 1,4 et donc n'ont pas décidé
ctc à bruxelles mais peut désormais
entrer en application en 1986 mais la
décision a désormais le champ libre
en même temps il débloque les sommes
accordées à la grande-bretagne à
stuttgart
c'était je crois 750 millions d'écus
bref le paquet fameux paquet dont on
avait commencé à parler à stuttgart est
désormais entièrement d'y nouer et
toutes les tous les objets sous toutes
les parties est comprise dans ce paquet
sont désormais acquises il n'est pas une
seule des questions ébauché à stuttgart
étudié à athènes
débloqués pour partie à bruxelles qui
reste aujourd'hui à disputer tout a été
décidé sur tous les points
ils s'étaient greffés voulait jeudi une
discussion sur une proposition allemande
cette proposition allemande dont était
une compensation une compensation
nationale pour que les agriculteurs
allemands puissent bénéficier non pas de
3% 2 5% tva variations qui se situe
exactement sur le même terrain et dans
les mêmes conditions que les 3 %
accordée à bruxelles avec une précision
écrite dans le texte à savoir que cette
somme doit rester strictement égal à la
compensation nécessaire qui doit
résulter de l'application de l'accord de
bruxelles sur les montants
compensatoires monétaire les dix ont
donné leur accord à cette mesure
nationale
ce n'est pas la première fois que cela
se produit mais les situations de
plusieurs filles sont différentes dans
ce domaine il arrivait même à la france
qui n'avait pas à demander l'accord de
la communauté pour ces aides nationales
le choisir d'autres techniques dead
n'est ces aides ont déjà existé par
exemple noël nous avions accepté nous
les français nous avions préféré faire
des aides structurelles à la production
des tiers c'était notre problème accord
a été conclu également sur ce point
entre le mois de juillet 1984 et le mois
de décembre 1988
j'aurais dû préciser tout à l'heure à
propos de la contribution britannique
que cet accord était strictement lié à
l'époque pendant lesquelles les
ressources propres nouvelles se
monteront 1,4 de la tva dès lors que
l'on serait conduit à augmenter alors la
discussion pourrait reprendre en tout
cas les accords a qui n'ont plus d'effet
et si une discussion du même ordre
devait être reprise à l'initiative de
tel ou tel membre de la communauté
ce serait sur la table rase de dire qu'
il a été entendu et décidé qu'il ne
pourrait pas y avoir deux précédents
bresse dans l'année qu'on peut supposer
se trouvait aux alentours de jabra biz
c'est la vie qui me qui nous dira qui a
raison aux alentours de 1987 3,8
peut-être quand les ressources propres
1,4 seront épuisés alors cet accord sur
des 66 % sans les droits des douaniers
sans les prélèvements d' intel pourra
être repris s'il est repris sur des
bases nouvelles
cela ne durera en tout cas pas plus
longtemps donc si les discussions sur le
passage à 1,6 prévu à osselle est
maintenu à fontainebleau à partir de la
date estimée aux alentours de 1988
à ce moment là naturellement cet accord
sera périmé
c'est d'enfin pourcentage pour un temps
limité d'autres discussions ont occupé
cette conférence de fontainebleau
elles ont toutes abouti je vais vous en
donner une liste rapide sans entrer dans
le vif du sujet
donc je vous ai dit augmentation des
ressources propres 1,4 1,6 rappel de ces
décisions de bruxelles
buts chez 84 85
il y a un déficit actuel qui n'est pas
réglée par les dispositions que je viens
d'évoquer
ce principe a donc été adopté cet après
midi ou plus exactement en fin de séance
de ce matin mais c'était déjà après midi
n'a été adoptée pour que ce déficit soit
couvert d avance par tous les procédés
qui seront proposées par la commission
et dès maintenant le conseil des
affaires générales et est chargé avec la
commission de mettre en pratique ce
principe
deuxièmement des orientations pour
l'élargissement ont été rappelés ou
fixez rappelé c'est la date de fin
septembre 1984 pour la négociation avec
vraisemblablement un retard pour la
négociation avec l'espagne
vraisemblement mais pas scruter et dans
ce cas là si cette hypothèse se
présenter il est demandé avec fermeté
aux négociateurs d'un avoir terminé dans
le courant de l'année 1984 le telle
sorte que les procédures de ratification
différentes selon les pays et en 1109
d'entrée de l'espagne du portugal aurait
lieu comme prévu le 1er janvier 1986 à
ce texte sur l'élargissement ont été
ajoutés à certains nombre de prévisions
en particulier la nécessité d'examiner
entre partenaires de la communauté et
avec l'espagne et le portugal
trois séries de problèmes en particulier
la maîtrise de la pêche la maîtrise de
la production
vino viticole du vin et l'harmonie dans
des dispositions qui sont prises entre
l'agriculture et l'industrie
le décision était prise sur deux tirs
monde c'était urgent puisque l'eau mais
doit avoir les instructions dans les
jours qui viennent
elles ont été prises selon les voeux de
la commission et les pays d'afrique des
caraïbes pacifique seront également
traités de la manière qui avait été
prévu faire que c'est également le
volume global
en chiffres réels qui avaient été
prévues dont on avait parlé à bruxelles
a été validé par la décision de
fontainebleau volume globale égale en
chiffres réels donc le maintien et non
pas la réduction d elle une de
résolution était une résolution et été
rappelé a été rappelé sur chypre et le
vityaz aux petits à bruxelles
depuis lors une résolution était adoptée
à l'organisation des nations unies donc
ils apparurent bon de rappeler notre
position la position unanime d'ailleurs
qui tend à ne pas rater des faits
accomplis dans les conditions vous savez
pour la souveraineté le shit et toute
une série de mesures alors tout à fait
nouvelle sur la construction de l'europe
ont été adoptés surtout sur le plan des
procédures car notre conseil aurait été
hors d'état de régler le fond de tous
ces problèmes en l'espace de quelques
heures
surtout quand je vous en aurez donné
l'énumération d'andré compte a été
décidé de créer un comité ad-hoc
c'est à dire de personnalités désigner
nommément par les chefs de gouvernement
ou chefs d'état échappant aux structures
traditionnelles mais en même temps sur
toutes les séries de points forts
importants en liaison ou à lisier hâtive
de la commission car il est beaucoup de
doutes de domaine prévue par le traité
de rome du moins dans les compétences
générales et qui trouvent leur
application pratique par avec annales de
la commission ils gardent tous ses
droits vie active au demeurant
c'était une des constatations les plus
fortes de la réunion de fontainebleau
que d'observer qu'il fallait restituer
aux structures héritées du traité de
rome toutes leurs forces commission ou
conseil des ministres en particulier
ceux qu'on appelait l'europe des
citoyens fera l'objet des travaux de ce
comité ad-hoc qui devra rendre heureux
les résultats de ces études dans le
courant de ce semestre
déjà je puis dire qu'un accord c'est
fait mais les modalités restent à
établir sur un document unique pour la
circulation des marchandises
à l'image de ce qui se fait à
l'intérieur du benelux un passeport
européen
la france a déjà édité ce passeport les
mêmes modalités ont été étudiées pendant
de longs mois par quelques spécialistes
devront être appliquées par les neuf
autres pays communautés européennes
république française
les formalités aux frontières vous savez
que la république fédérale allemande et
république française ont décidé de
procéder sans délai à l'élimination de
tout contrôle sur le passage des
personnes sur leurs frontières
je veux dire rien contre le droit y est
resté des contrôles de police bien
entendu terrorisme drogue fraudes de
toutes sortes mais le contrôle douanier
sera levé ne reste ne sera donc que
l'exception
la banalisation terme peu obscur qui
signifie que la banalisation des postes
de douane signifierait qu'il y aurait
des postes de douane unique pour les
deux pays n'ont pas partout pour
l'instant mais pour point de départ un
certain nombre qui seraient tenus par
les deux pays brashear est pas de
passages frontières américains et ceux
retenus soit par la soie par l'ocde pays
ça dépend des arrangements soit par les
deux à la fois sur thur et des équipes
mixtes
là où il n'y aurait pas d'accord sur les
personnes puisque pour l'instant
l'accord dont je vous parle ne concerne
que les allemands et les français et
c'est à l'imitation de cet accord entre
français et allemands que les autres
sont invités à s'y joindre et toute une
série de propositions qui seront
examinées pour cette europe des citoyens
aussi bien donc j'ai parlé des passages
de douane des formalités des passeports
pour les marchandises aussi re prépare
les des équivalences pour les diplômes
les études universitaires des échanges
de classe l'idée un peu plus nouvelle
peut être celle des volontaires
européens pour le tiers-monde
les jumelages entre classes mais même là
même été question de la frappe de l'écu
de la chaîne de télévision européenne
sur un canal telle était d'ailleurs la
proposition française dans le cadre de
ses travaux
tels que vous les avez connus avant que
toutes les séries de propositions
divergentes ne vienne oblitérer cette
proposition qui sera inévitablement
reprises bon j'en passe
en tout cas tel est le programme un
développement des toute autre
proposition qui pourrait survenir sous
l'autorité de monsieur fils gérald qui
devient à partir du 1er juillet
président de la communauté irlande
indépendamment de toute autre initiative
de ce type pour que l'europe des
personnes l'europe des citoyens puissent
se mettre en mouvement de mal même
procédure pour l'environnement autour
d'un texte très précis
l'état aussi bien des pluies acides de
la déforestation de la pollution des des
fleuves des rivières de du plomb dans
l'essence été arrêté à son arrivée à une
réglementation européenne profitant des
travaux effectués par toute une série
d'organisations notamment actuellement
un congrès à munich qui réunit les pays
de l'est et les piles ouest sur ce sujet
certaines suggestions frais à versailles
il ya deux ans et redites récemment à
londres même disposition pour la
biologie et la santé il était entendu
que toute une série de d'études et de
projets européens devront être décidées
dans l'année 1984 pour une politique
européenne propre à la biologie et à la
santé et on trouve la réplique de ce que
je viens de vous dire dans le domaine de
la recherche et de l'industrie
car priorité vient d'être décidée
aujourd'hui pour que dès maintenant il
soit procédé à des démarches européenne
harmonisation dans l'industrie de la
biotechnologie et des télécommunications
il ya bien d'autres domaines alors est
ce ces deux là ont déjà été décidées
de même sur le plan culturel mais là ce
sont les milices de la culture qui se
sont réunis ces derniers jours ils vont
pas nous aurons fait connaître les
résultats leurs travaux mais de toute
façon il y as habilitation pour les
poursuivre on pense en particulier à d
harmonisation fiscale dans ce domaine
culturel et aussi dans bien d'autres
mais seulement sur le plan industriel et
aussi de la création intellectuelle et
artistique l'espace comité réflexion sur
les projets de station spatiale orbitale
à partir de ce que l'on connaît sur les
résultats d'ariane ariane 5 qui que vous
avez sera en mesure de lancer les
stations habités dans l'espace
cela nécessitera beaucoup de temps et
d'argent
d'où notre volonté d'étudier ce problème
dès maintenant sur le plan de l'espace
social européen
toute une série de dispositions tourne
essentiellement autour de la formation
et de la lutte contre le chômage lutte
contre la drogue
voici l'ensemble des domaines dont la
plupart sont nouveaux et qui désormais
vont entrer dans la pratique quotidienne
de la communauté dans le cadre de ces
sujets j'ai parlé de comité ad-hoc
mais je vous épargnerai une précision
par rapport à chacune des ses
orientations plus de la moitié de ces
orientations relève de la compétence de
la commission et à l'intérieur de
chacune de ces rubriques il y a déjà des
compétences accordées par les traités et
les accords froid donc que la commission
prenne des initiatives et que ces
initiatives soit en harmonie et
coordonnée avec celle des comités
spécialisés
monsieur le président de la commission
qui se trouve
du côté mettra en oeuvre l'ensemble de
ce dispositif
voilà mesdames et messieurs ce que je
puis vous dire c'est assez long mais en
même temps c'est assez bref parce que je
viens de vous résumer en quelques
minutes
l'objet de travaux qui ont été fort long
et est très absorbant pendant les
nombreuses heures qui nous ont occupés
depuis hier matin
il en aurait terminé lorsque je vous
dirais que la même procédure a été
adoptée toujours un insistant sur le
rôle de la commission pour donner une
structure politique de la communauté un
élan nouveau un contenu un élan et sans
doute aussi que l'on définisse de façon
plus précise
leur compétence relative bulles façon
générale d'ailleurs partout retraités ou
à l'esprit du traité
mais en allant sur certains points que
loisir en reprenant sur le plan d'études
le plan guen cher colombo les
propositions du sens et nicolas stoddart
les propositions que j'ai fait moi-même
à strasbourg d'autres propositions
multiples touchant ta route de la
commission rôle du conseil des ministres
rôle du conseil européen qui devrait
désormais s'occuper soit d'arbitrer les
conflits qui n'aurait pu l'être
auparavant soit de lancer les grandes
décisions politiques comme nous l'avons
fait aujourd'hui
et puis l'exacte nature du secrétariat
politique plus actif et plus complet que
cela ne peut être le cas aujourd'hui en
raison des compétences accordées par le
traité de robes l'ensemble de ses
structures politiques sera comme à une
autre époque et par assimilation traité
indépendamment de la commission au plus
tôt à partir des propositions de la
commission par une sorte de comité
également
haddock adapté à cette tâche je répète à
l'image de ce qui fut fait naguère
lorsque l'on a appelé les spécialistes
nombre ici s'y reconnaîtront très bien
le comité ce pack des personnalités
fonctionnaires ou pas désignés par
chaque chef du gouvernement chef d'état
se réunissent en dehors de toute
procédure gardant un lien extrêmement
étroits avec le président de la
commission qui a naturellement droit
automatique de participer à tous ces
travaux et qui doit nous remettre dans
le plus bref délai des propositions pour
que l'union politique de l'europe soirée
serré tout cela en relation avec le
parlement européen qui sera saisie de
l'ensemble de ces propositions qui en
sera en tout cas personne de son bureau
et de son président informez constamment
dernière question la présidence de la
commission
il a été décidé d'observer une procédure
semblable à celle où à peu près
semblable à celle qui a prévalu la
dernière fois lorsque le président
thorne a été désigné on s'en souviendra
c'était à l'époque une présidence
italienne celle de monsieur cossiga
président du conseil des ministres
d'italie et monsieur cossiga avait
d'abord interrogé les uns les autres ce
que j'ai fait moi-même au cours de ces
quinze derniers jours et remis
l'ensemble de ces propositions examinées
l'ensemble de ces propositions puisqu'il
continuait lui d'être le président et
dans les trois semaines qui ont suivi le
conseil il a obtenu l'accord de tous sur
le foie de l'actuel président monsieur
gaston tort nous inspirons de cette
procédure mais là il ya un changement de
présidence du à roulement semestriel
s'est donc monsieur fitzgerald qui
réunira dans les jours qui viennent
l'ensemble des propositions qui lui
seront transmises celle dont j'ai déjà
connaissance et qui dans le courant du
mois de juillet sera une proposition
à l'ensemble des paiements voilà
mesdames et messieurs je propose avoir
tout dit ou à peu près tous en tout cas
l'essentiel est maintenant je l'attends
vos questions si d'antenne 2 messieurs
le monsieur le président philippe
sassier d'antenne 2 à votre avis est-ce
que cet accord sur la contribution
britannique qui a empoisonné
l'atmosphère de l'europe pendant des
mois parce que cela marque une véritable
relance de l'europe
ou bien est-ce que cela permet de gagner
du temps puisque vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure vous même on aura enfin les
européens auront de nouveau des
problèmes financiers dans deux ou trois
ans alors on gagne du temps bien ce que
c'est une relance très forte
c'est une relance très forte puisque
cette affaire de la contribution
britannique bloquer un certain nombre de
décisions prises forte importantes
prises notamment à bruxelles
je pense à l'augmentation des ressources
propres de la communauté et à
l'élargissement de la même communauté
et d'autre part il était très difficile
d'engager un débat de fond sur la
politique sur l'union européenne sur
l'union politique de la communauté tant
que l'on traîné derrière soi un
contentieux aussi des dix fils
cela est en fait non seulement les
autres et contentieux ont été tout aussi
tout débloquer élargissement ressources
propres arriérés de ceux qui étaient
engagés l'égard de la grande-bretagne en
1983 frais sur ce procès c'est à dire le
taux 1,4 1,6 délai d'élargissement avec
l'espagne et le portugal nature vu les
bars pêche 20 et ses industries tout ça
étant débloquer le but de relance très
forte à tout aussitôt été décidé puisque
dans la foulée nous avons pu régler le
problème récent posées par l'allemagne
et des passants cet objet l'a décidé le
principe du règlement du déficit
budgétaire actuel et dépassant de loin
tout cela engager toute une série de
politiques nouvelles que je vous résume
vrai en dix ans les tic nouvelle europe
des citoyens sont valides frontières
passage personnes marchandises
équivalence universitaire diplôme toute
une série d'initiatives tendance à
associer l'europe dans des démarches de
toutes sortes de informations chaîne de
télévision surtout culture naturellement
jumelage environnement biologie santé
culture recherche industrie
biotechnologies et télécommunications
espace projet de station orbitale espace
social européen lutte contre la drogue
et enfin ce qui est la marque décisive
de cette relance la remise en chantier
des structures sur la base du traité de
rome et donc se rapprochant du moment où
l'élan initial tout donner pour repartir
vers de nouveaux horizons adapté à ce
que nous pouvons connaître du monde en
c'est donc une forte relance de l'europe
communauté européenne à laquelle nous
venons d'assister à la conférence de
fontainebleau
monsieur le président georges bartoli gc
voudrais monsieur bartoli peut être que
tu le faire plus tôt mais pour votre
information soit plus complète encore et
vous ne parliez messieurs vous retient
tout de suite pour répondre à votre
question
aussitôt après monsieur tourne fort et
peut être complétée ce que j'ai dit ah
enfin tel qu'il le voit lui-même
je remercie beaucoup monsieur le
président mais je pourrais très bref
après les explications que vous avez
donnée mais devrait associer quand même
la commission et et dire que ce qui
était essentiel c'est que nous
remettions l'europe en marche le
président de la république l'a souligné
avant de relancer avant de s'engager
dans de nouvelles politiques fallait
garantir qu'on est la cohésion
nécessaire et est donc déblayer le
terrain de
problème qui nous a beaucoup disons le
franchement empoisonné et qui a bloqué
pendant très pendant trop longtemps mais
je suis heureux que grâce à la
présidence française en tête grâce aux
prises dans la république à nationaliste
cheysson dumas et tous leurs
collaborateurs
pendant ces six mois on a travaillé
d'arrache-pied et bien on y est parvenu
peut être un peu plus tard au cours de
la journée qu'on l'avait espéré ou
souhaités mais c'est chose faite
alors vous demandiez valeur oui on gagne
en toute hypothèse du temps il faut
gagner du temps dans la vie si on veut
se préparer de nouveaux devoirs et allez
de nouveau de l'avant mais le président
de la république l'a expliqué n'y a pas
que ça je lui suis reconnaissante
aujourd'hui d'avoir mais mis les doigts
sur les petites choses d'avoir refait un
peu de cette europe des citoyens pour la
rendre tangible à chacun de nos citoyens
et d'ouvrir les perspectives d'avenir et
lucas mois souhaité qu'on puisse être
plus précis aller de l'avant hélas le
problème budgétaire nous a encore trop
bloqué mais la voie royale la voie
européenne disent on est maintenant
ouverte et à monsieur gerets il geraghty
aux autres qui nous accompagneront
d'aller de l'avant dans ce domaine
l'élargissement aussi redevient possible
et beaucoup de politiques nouvelles
enfin nous pourrons répondre aux défis
que nous pose le temps présent voilà ce
que je voulais dire en résumé ce qui est
essentiel à un regret c'est que le temps
nous fut mesurée et que donc nous
n'avons pas pu résoudre tous les
problèmes budgétaires qui se pose
maintenant les ressources propres sont
approuvés en principe il nous faudra
encore régler le problème budgétaire de
84,85 mais on a pris l'engagement de le
faire à courte échéance donc tous les
espoirs sont permis et même mon art
recentrer les problèmes et on a remis le
problème institutionnel là où il devait
toujours être c'est-à-dire en première
ligne et on s'est préoccupé de l'avenir
sans toucher entre et faut traiter sans
jamais vouloir remettre en question les
traiter voilà tout ce que j'avais a
ajouté monsieur président et ou à
confirmer
j'ajouterai simplement qu'il n'y a plus
un seul contentieux existant dans les
bras d'autres
c'est la vie mais à la date où je
m'exprime par rapport à ce que je
connais personnellement depuis 1981
premier sommet celui de londres
il n'existe plus un seul des contentieux
que j'ai trouvé en 80 gens tant que
membre de la confiance ou qui sont nés
depuis lors ne restent pas seuls et la
remarque de monsieur thot s'applique aux
déficits actuels qui la dernière
question à régler qui ne pouvaient pas
l'être par un organisme qui n'a pas
vocation pour cela mais qui avait une
occasion pour donner l'ordre politique
de couvrir ce déficit
il appartient maintenant aux instances
qualifié d' employer les procédés qui
paraîtront les meilleurs et en plus de
cela sert la liquidation de tous les
contentieux sans exception neuf
chantiers nouveaux ont été ouverts la
compétence de la communauté européenne
huit chantiers du nord de l'europe des
citoyens l'environnement et cetera et
cetera et un neuvième
l'europe politique monsieur bartoli
président je voulais vous demander si
dans cette affaire de la contribution
britannique
certains ont fait plus de concessions
que d'autres ou si vous décerner un
brevet décale bonne volonté à tous après
ce que vous venez dire honnêtement
jamais je ne peux que déclaré que légal
bonne volonté c'est un soudain saisi des
dix délégations dans un élan
d'enthousiasmé inattendue nous sommes
parvenus en fin à l'accord je suis
encore président de la communauté
pendant voyons nous sommes le 22 6 et
bien encore quatre jours je resterai
diplomate quatre jours
dans la réalité les la contribution
accordée a plutôt le la restitution sur
la contribution accordée en 1981 a
représenté en fait parce qu'il ya eu un
trop perçu 110 à 130 % de la
contribution britannique 110 à 130 %
dire qu'on lui a rendu plus qu'elle
n'avait versé au total c'est ce qui
m'avait paru un peu excessif sans trop
perçu l'accord repose et s'il n'y avait
pas eu trop peur si ce désir une
mauvaise estimation du chiffre du
déficit prévisible
c'était 80 % sur le papier c'est et 110
à 130 les demandes de britanniques ont
varié
lorsqu elle reposait sur les
prélèvements agricoles et sur les taxes
douanières elles pouvaient se contenter
d'être plus modestes mais la modestie
s'arrêter quand même deux tiers lorsque
il n'était plus question d de ressources
communautaires taxes douanières et
prélèvements agricoles pour obtenir le
même chiffre de calcul britannique
montait plus haut saisir eux au moins
aux trois quarts dans certains calculs
mais m'ont approché 90% ce qui
d'ailleurs est ressortez de
l'encouragement donné en 1981 finalement
il a été décidé
66% sur la contribution britannique
après soustraction des déficits est en
déficit
je reste un peu trop déficit britannique
annuel examiné annuellement ce 66%
restant la règle - les deux dates sont
prestations que j'ai cités dire sur un
chiffre inférieur et cela jusqu'à
épuisement des ressources propres
nouvelles 1,4 monsieur le président
c'est le président vous l'appréciez pour
le reste c'est le président monsieur
monsieur le président écoutez sur des
personnes là j'ai vu monsieur alors j'ai
saisi c'est ce monsieur qui la dispense
tel cri de libération
la solution des problèmes de la
contribution britannique et des
problèmes budgétaires
va-t-elle entraîner une augmentation de
la contribution française j'essaierai de
vous dire et c'est vrai je n'ai pas dit
que l'allemagne qui participaient
jusqu'à lors pour la moitié de ce
qu'elle devait dire 18% des 36% de sa
part sur la tva va passer des 18 à 24 %
c'est-à-dire de la moitié ou des tiers
il ya donc une augmentation de la part
allemande ce qui entraîne
automatiquement une diminution de la
part française en pourcentage
naturellement et de tous les autres
en pourcentage des chiffres étant
variable progrès du déficit
on ne peut pas les prévoir on peut
prévoir malheureusement que le déficit
augmentera au loin d'élargissement mais
on ne peut pas prévoir exactement le
c'est pour ça que le pourcentage était
nécessaire mais je n'ai pas de vue oui
christine clerc est bien ce qui est un
privilège pour moi a reconnu votre voix
mais je vous vois pas je cite là haut
ces foyers dans ceux dont la voix j'ai
la vue c'est parti
cet accord aura t'il selon vous pour
conséquence de diminuer le
mécontentement qui s'est exprimé
récemment en france en particulier à
l'occasion des élections européennes
contre la politique de votre
gouvernement au sol dans six règlements
rien parce que je m'étonne de plus en
plus de ce mécontentement et qui me
paraît vraiment peu fondées puisque je
comprends très bien lorsqu'il s'agit de
catégories socioprofessionnelles
durement touché par la crise et par
l'effort pour un jeu de restructuration
industrielle engagée par ce gouvernement
est en même temps de tenue de nos prix
pour éviter que l'inflation des
contrarie toutes deux à trois de
redressement
donc c'est dur pour ces catégories là
mais pour ce qui est du mécontentement
est-ce qui se greffe sur ces situations
malheureuses que nous entendons
précisément corrigé par les résultats de
notre politique à laquelle nous sommes
appliqués alors là je le prétends à rien
madame je ne prétends pas que l'europe
occupe à ce point les esprits et soit en
mesure de répondre à toutes les
questions
pour tout citoyen impartiale honnête et
réfléchie de votre jean cela paraîtra
évident monsieur le président il ya un
mot s'il vous plaît que vous n'avez pas
prononcé dans le préambule des votes sur
le préambule que ça fait sur les travaux
du conseil c'est le mot terrorisme
donc vous savez qu'il ya beaucoup de
pays comme communautaire qui souffrent
est ce que le conseil n'a pas abordé
cette question ou bien s'il est ici ne
l'a pas volé est-ce que cela a une
signification particulière gg de très
brefs sur le contenu de leur rapport de
madame thatcher après londres qui est
occupée comme à 1h30 de notre
conversation en début de travail hier
matin
et parmi les questions qui avait été
très à londres vous vous souviendrez
qu'il y avait le terrorisme et cela a de
nouveau été évoqué c'est à dire que la
communauté entend bien se donner à
elle-même les moyens qui ont été évoqués
au sommet de londres façon harmonisée au
politique et alors j'ai été quand même
un mot tout à l'heure le mot a été
prononcé contrairement à ce que ben brik
mais vous avez le droit d'être d'istres
et lorsque j'ai dit que pour le passage
libre les frontières terrorisme drogue
en particulier serait de même l'objet
d'observations de police tout n'est pas
permis
monsieur le président monsieur le
président radio suisse romande andré
rousselet
cette volonté de relance politique
manifesté aujourd'hui par les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement n'est-elle pas
un peu ternie par la réaction des
citoyens des pays européens qui ne se
sont pas déplacés en très grand nombre
lors des élections européennes il y a
dix jours
naturellement vu de suisse bon peut-être
peut-être pas ça vient peut-être un peu
tard je risque était que ce fut plutôt à
vous de commenter monsieur le président
il françois tellement agence radio ercom
france capte munication mais ces
pressions il avait été question je crois
d'étudier l'éventualité de création
peut-être dans l'avenir d'un drapeau
européen voire même si j'ai bien compris
d'un hymne européen
cette information est elle prématurée
non elle fait partie avaient fait des
décisions prises vais vous épargner
liste qui aurait qui vous aurait tenu un
quart d'heure de plus qu'à une très
longue liste mais emblème en effet il ya
imminent il y a équipes sportives
européennes fait beaucoup de choses
encore riez réservons les bonnes
surprises que chaque mois porte sa
moisson nouvelles d'information
si je dis tout aujourd'hui ça mon 400 m
haies puis sur certaines des choses que
je viens de dire ne se font pas alors
qu'est-ce que je n'entendrais plus tard
ça que je suis très présent mais c'est
le président florentino de la junte
chronos vous avez à côté de votre
exposition initial les projets des
traités pour le numéro un du parlement
européen du parlement et qui a
strasbourg déclarés prêts à examiner
défendre
j'ai l'impression qu'ils vous avez été
moins chaleureux
rapport à ces projets est ce que vous
allez faire strasbourg écoutez il faut
que j'étudie monteton mamine que l'on
trouve quelquefois un peuple m c'est à
dire le cas depuis hier matin
je voudrais bien vous y voir un se met à
y voir mais ça va plutôt bien et elle ne
supporte que le démontre ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que aujourd'hui on a
adopté pour la première fois un comité
dit ce pacte dont des professionnels
ulrich bon connaisseur des problèmes de
l'europe du journalisme au programme
pour ça parce que ça veut dire
le système qui a réussi et qui doit
réussir pour que le contenu j'ai cité
des propositions geisha colombo des
propositions colas ou degas et de mon
propre discours de strasbourg puisse
entrer dans les faits nous avons créé la
procédure avec mission d'aboutir comme
comme vous savez il ya divers pays qui
font sur ces propositions des réserves
extrême les dix pays de la communauté ne
sont pas exactement en harmonie sur ce
point les six pays est originaire
oui et c'est acide d'autres encore pas
tous c'est donc une discussion qui
s'ouvre mais cette discussion créé
obligation pour les pays qui s'en sont
convaincus et qui de toute manière
houdré rond pour eux ce chemin
si le président de questions
j'ai également parlé du parlement tout à
l'heure en disant qu'ils seraient saisis
non sire nous louer le liban une
question européenne si vous permettez
une autre moyen orientale la première
ayant réussi à résoudre le contentieux
régler le problème
de cette communauté est ce que vous
comptez mais est ce que maintenant la
l'europe pour les marchés à une seule
vitesse autrement dit est-ce que la
question du double vitesse et autonome
indépendante de la question de
deuxièmement est-ce que vous avez
traiter du problème du moyen-orient est
ce que le conseil va répondre à la
requête de lancé par le secrétaire de la
ligue arabe pour tenir une conférence
internationale sur le moyen orient et
merci sur l'europe à deux vitesses la
question a été posée par un participant
j'irai ailleurs tenu à préciser que
chaque fois que j'avais parlé de ces
sujets moi même après beaucoup d'autres
géométrie variable de vitesse toutes
façons d expression visuelle depuis déjà
plusieurs années
mais lorsque je l'envoyais je n'ai
jamais dit la communauté à des vitesses
j'ai toujours dire l'europe à des
vitesses exemple le jet acclame en
angleterre les dix pays la communauté
puisse la suède puis ça suisse ce qu'il
géométrie variable par rapport à la
communauté alice ce v12 exemple airbus
bon grande bretagne allemagne italie
france espagne l'espagne non encore
membres de la communauté
chermiti variable ariane bien d'autres
projets peuvent être à géométrie
variable pour l'europe tel ou tel pays
de l'europe des 10,2 s'interdit pas de
travailler à la construction européenne
avec dépit qu'il n'ya pas retiennent pas
n'est ce pas monsieur
c'est le cas de ceux que j'ai été
visités à genève
c'est également le cas de ceux que je
viens d'évoquer c'est à dire le jet à
londres donc la communauté à deux
vitesses ça poserait d'autres problèmes
que je n'ai jamais abordé
si la communauté telle qu'elle est
s'étaient refusées à tout avance en
toute relance le problème ce serait
certainement posé pour les partisans
d'une europe vivante active les progrès
de cette journée
permette pour l'instant d'en faire
l'économie et d'avoir confiance dans la
réussite de ces diverses relance nous
jugerons sur pièce sur la deuxième
question moyen orient nous avons en
effet reçu la lettre de monsieur klibi
jeter général de la ligue arabe
à propos de cette conférence est nous
avons renvoyé à au conseil des ministres
dont c'est d'ailleurs la tasse car après
tout notre conseil européen s'est occupé
mamou courtier deux dernières journées
d'un certain nombre de questions qui
auraient pu et de la compétence du
conseil des ministres comme ça avait
pris beaucoup de retard
on a préféré le faire et bien cette
question sera examinée par le conseil
des ministres le président régis shalom
à propos du moyen orient toujours est ce
que les conversations que vous avez eue
avec monsieur papandréou vous permet de
telles de penser que son pays
reconnaîtra l'état d'israël et dans la
négative est ce que les pays européens
peuvent l'accepter
eh bien cher monsieur je les dois dire à
ma plus grande conclusion que je n'ai
pas songé à lui poser la question
malgré l'extrême attention que je porte
au problème du proche orient je n'ai pas
pensé à demander à monsieur papandréou
si son pays reconnaîtrez ni ce rêve
ailleurs mais connaissant je crois qu'il
a reconnu m'a pas dérangé les sens mais
bien pas de relations diplomatiques
c'est encore plus subtile dans les cas
de l'espagne ne crois pas le portugal
n'y a pas si longtemps
non donc nous n'avons pas parlé je nous
allons maintenant je vais vous quitter
paris monsieur rousseau du corriere
della serra di milano équipe où je peux
avoir votre jugement sur le rôle que la
délégation l'italien a joué
blocage dans le déblocage du conflit
avec la grande bretagne et ses comptes
question est-ce que vous pensez que
l'italie sera plus disposée à collaborer
pour acheter l'airbus ont pour faire une
collaboration technologique et même pour
l'alarmisme en cela à la communauté
européenne avec l'espagne merci
contribution remarquable d'une
efficacité rare
monsieur c'est à dire la question je
m'en vais les radios madrid avant de
partir demain pour lisbonne et madrid
est ce que vous pourriez risquer à un
pronostic pour le match de football ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que je ne
peux pas pas pour lisbonne et madrid
je vais demain à lisbonne déjeuner du
palais dorés à et à revenir dans l'après
midi afin de faire un peu de travail à
l'elysée et d'aller au match final de la
coupe d'or du championnat d'europe au
parc des princes et ce n'est que le
surlendemain vendredi que j'irai pour
quelques heures à madrid rencontre et
felipe gonzalez bord et puis le roi
d'espagne
voilà donc monopoly temps je ne fais pas
un circuit
j'ai fait des voyages et c'est tout à
fait volontaire même si ça me prend un
peu plus de temps
quant aux pronostics
ce n'est pas cher une mauvaise manière à
l'égard de l'espagne dont vous êtes le
porte parole ici que de dire je serais
quand même assez content de voir
l'équipe de france gagner mais si c'est
l'espagne dégage je dirais pas seulement
il rentre à gagner merci